yo what's up everybody man luigi here
with some more fallout 4 calm 10 a
bullet for is right around the corner
it's almost out so I'm really excited
making this video I'm excited hope you
guys are excited hope this video gets
you more excited soap that further ado
let's get into what this video is about
this video is going to be about the
companion system in fallout 4 and
looking back on previous fallout
companion systems what we can look to
expect hopefully the positives or the
negatives of that so looking back to the
safe all new vegas or fallout 3 become
bad the combat with the companions was
really to me it wasn't the best because
there were so many companions that were
really really really strong like you can
see in the gameplay of new vegas that
i'm showing i have two companions rex
and Veronica Veronica attendants to one
hit almost all the standard human
characters and Rex will search the
entire map local area to just kill
everything and it'll take like 10
chairman guards to make him go
unconscious and now this is all saying
he's still alive so he just gets down if
I finished the fight without him being
alive being conscious and then I just
wait a little bit he's revived and he's
way too ready to fight again now the
thing is with the companion system that
i think is not super good in the
previous games is that the companions
can be really powerful and then they
just don't die so if you have a super
strong companion that just killed
everything there's not a lot of there's
not a lot of gameplay that you can do
yourself since every fight you have is
just lesson by the fact that you have
just an invincible killing machine with
you that it's just going to destroy
everything regardless of what you do now
looking to fallout 4 we've seen dog me
as a companion he's really the only
companion that they've showcase being a
companion we know they're gonna be about
liked well like a dozen or so companions
and they might all be as powerful as dog
me they might be stronger than might be
weaker dog need does have a lot of perks
festive specifically forums so it does
look like he's gonna be really really
strong and he can't die we know that he
can't dive been told that he cannot die
so we have a really strong companion
that can die they're just gonna go kill
everything again I don't know if that's
gonna be the best thing to have so I'm
hoping that they make sure to make not
too powerful so that even if you have
him music
onion or other companions you still have
to do the majority of the work as the
player in the game so if there's a group
of enemies if your dog might help you
kill him but not kill all of them let
you just back since in New Vegas I just
went through I just went to see how much
Rex would kill and he would just kill
everything I walk down the strip of
vegas and i just killed every single
bought and guard in the strip of new
vegas and i just i took it over it like
the game was over cuz I controlled the
strip but yeah that's kind of the video
I hope you guys enjoyed this leave your
comments about what you think the
companion system should be like if you
like the previous games combat system if
you think that fallout 4 is combat
system is companion system sorry it's
going to be similar is gonna be
different it's going to be good that
yeah so I'm I'm hopeful that they'll
make the proper changes they need to
wear dog knee will be a good companion
other companions would be good and they
won't be too powerful so yeah hope you
have enjoyed this and get excited for
Fallout 4 I know I am thank you for
watching peace out